la cárcel de Bin es la más importante de
todo Irán y es famosa porque allí es
donde se llevan a la mayoría de los
presos políticos del país incluido
cientos de personas que han sido
detenidas en los últimas semanas en el
marco de esta Nueva Ola de protestas que
ya entra en la quinta semana de allí el
miedo que tenían muchísimas familias en
la noche de ayer que se acercaban hasta
esta prisión pitando o seguidores que de
de estas protestas tratando de dar apoyo
a quienes se encontraban allí adentro
las autoridades han dicho que lo que
sucedió allí dentro de la prisión no
tienen nada que ver con las protestas
que ayer veíamos una nueva jornada con
movilizaciones no solamente enteran sino
en el resto de Irán con imágenes
bastante violentas y bastante represión
sin embargo las autoridades dicen hasta
el momento de que esto surgió por
enfrentamientos entre dos de las salas
más importantes de la cárcel donde
estarían ellos convictos por haber por
robo especialmente y otros por
corrupción financiera sin embargo las
versiones siguen siendo bastante
confusas según han denunciado a las
familias los detenidos los prisioneros
políticos que están adentro incluidos
aquellos que tienen doble nacionalidad
especialmente norteamericanos o
franceses algunos de ellos han llamado a
sus familias y han dicho que se
encuentran bien sin embargo el temor es
bastante grande porque nadie sabe
realmente lo que sucedió durante las
horas el fuego ya está controlado sin
embargo las autoridades dicen que al
menos cuatro personas murieron y 61
personas habrían quedado heridas por
haber inhalado esos gases lacrimógenos
sin embargo las versiones de anoches en
las cercanías a la cárcel de vine hablan
de muchas ambulancias que estuvieron
cerca y que trasladaron a personas por
fuera de este centro penitencia